House Democrats say they are expanding
their investigation of potential
criminal conduct by the president
they're looking into allegations made by
his former personal attorney Michael
Cohen some Republicans say Cohen lied
under oath in his testimony Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill where Cohen finished
three days of testimony yesterday Nancy
good morning good morning all told Cohen
testified here on Capitol Hill this week
for about 30 hours and he's coming back
for more next Wednesday bringing with
him additional evidence Democrats say
that Cohen laid out quote a roadmap of
criminality committed by the president
now they're going to hear from another
longtime Trump ally Felix aider on March
14th they believe Sator played an
integral role and talks about a Trump
business deal during the campaign that
the president has downplayed the
committee also plans to call the Trump
organizations chief financial officer
Alan weiselberger to discuss his alleged
involvement in hush money payments to
stormy Daniels meanwhile a pair of
Republican Congressman Jim Jordan mark
meadows are accusing Cohen of perjury
now and referring it to the Justice
Department
they say he lied Wednesday about his
hopes of working at the White House and
a bunch of other things Cohen's lawyer
Lanny Davis called it a baseless
criminal referral by two pro-trump
committee members in a new interview
just last night the president called
Cohen quote not much of a lawyer and
said that these hearings bianna were a
terrible display of dishonesty then
quite a week for Michael Cohen we'll
hear from him again next week Nancy
thank you